Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Qualche giorno
fa ho fatto una sorpresa a Luigi e ho
preparato questa cena carina nella quale
mi sono messo a fare la pasta fatta in
casa. Ho fatto delle stories che adesso
vi faccio vedere velocemente. Allora 320
grammi di farina, ci dovevo mettere tre
uova, ne ho messo uno. Ora vedo se ci riesco con il
secondo a farlo con una mano. Tac, tiè, Sbam!
Pazzesco! Cracco ciao! Il terzo dai così di fila perché non ho
paura della diretta. Oddio lo sto spappolando. Goccettino nino nino. O no sta uscendo
distruggendoli. Un pizzico d'amore, tiè,
abbondare. Fate una palettina...e la fate
riposare per 30 minuti, bella. E poi
deve stare in un luogo freddo. Io ho
deciso il mio balcone lì. E tra i vari
commenti che ricevo in privato su
Instagram, ho letto un po' di "Senti devi provare a
fare una puntata di Cucina Buttata nella
quale fai la pasta fatta in casa con
una sola mano". In realtà ho preso spunto
da questa idea e ho pensato invece di
renderla ancora più divertente. Prima di
tutto chiamando qui Luigi. Ciao. Buonasera. Chef (Rico)
Chef  Louis...Invece di fare la pasta fatta in casa a
quattro mani, di farla comunque a due
mani e quindi io potrò usare la sinistra
e lui potrà utilizzare solamente la
destra. Io direi che ci siamo possiamo partire a
questo punto col procedimento.
Il grembiule (Rico). Il grembiule
No già la sinistra non so schioccare, schiocca tu con la destra
Ok, allora a questo punto abbiamo il
grembiule, abbiamo tutto quanto, iniziamo
a fare la pasta fatta in casa
Nessuno si dà il 5 da solo però vabbè...Per fare
la pasta fatta in casa abbiamo bisogno
della farina, uova, sale e olio.
Molte persone, tipo dell'Emilia Romagna
quando hanno visto che io metto un
goccetto di olio hanno detto "No non si fa
mai! Bisogna mettere 100 g di farina
ogni uovo". E' vero avete ragione ma io ho
imparato a metterci sempre un pizzichino di
olio, mi sento che devo farlo. E' così
sbagliato? Cioè gli emiliani e i romagnoli
lo sanno meglio di chiunque altro come
si fa la pasta fatta in casa. Boh
in realtà si è forse un goccino goccino
Ma forse perché a Napoli...a Napoli si usa mettere...in qualsiasi impasto
Nel latte e caffè. No qualsiasi impasto. Ti prendevo in giro. Olè, sale
Si ma tutti i pacchi di farina perdono
farina a priori. Apriamola...Signori dei
supermercati, ma perché, o signori di Frumenta
ma perché la farina è fatta per perdere
farina quando la apri. Era qua, era fuori
era già messa fuori non poteva, non
poteva non uscire . Pierfrancesco ha detto
di usare tutte le uova, quindi c'è un
altro uovo in frigo. Un'altra uova. Il 2/4
E' andata. 600 grammi, sei uova. Mamma mia la
difficoltà e pensare che so pure mancino
Ce n'è uno già sfrantumato
Ok fermo non lo rovinare ancora
di più, quello lì ci serve
Il vulcano. Questa è dura eh! Io lo reggo
Bravo...Ma tu l'hai sfondato! Posso provarci un attimo da solo? Almeno adesso avrò tutta la
responsabilità. Ma perché non ti sei già
preso la responsabilità di quello?
Ammazza (Rico)! Provo con la sinistra?
Ho buttato dentro tutto. Prova così
Bravissimo!...Bene. Sì, devo dire che questa qui è
andata bene
Pesantina sta pasta (Mario). Madonna ragazzi (Rico)!
Ho capito ci mangeranno un po' di persone , n'è che te la magni tutta te. Pizzico di sale
Io non il senso della misura, per me pizzico è tipo un pugno. Aspetta diamoci una sciacquatina
Da qui sembrate un'unica persona considerate. E da qui?...Pizzico di sale
Ottimo... e un micro micro micro filino
d'olio. Ragazzi fatemi sapere se è
veramente così una bestemmia, apriamo un
dibattito. Olio si olio no. Mi sa che
è no, ma chi è che ce lo mette? E perché?
Cri cri cri (Rico). Basta? Sei stato bravissimo
Ho ricevuto una critica, mi hanno detto che non
si può usare la forchetta per unire. Mani mani (Rico)
Perché le nonne ti uccidono. Ok. Quindi
dobbiamo fare questo. Devi solamente
lavorare il centro. Oddio ma è quasi
piacevole
Oddio sto facendo...No hai fatto una c*****a! Si anche secondo me. Fidati
con la forchetta ti sporca molto
di meno
Guarda sono il Grinch. Col palmo...vai. No io
ho paura di far casino. E invece così
ti sta andando da Dio. Così stai facendo
veramente un ottimo lavoro
Ora dobbiamo lavorarci questa, però con due mani lo dobbiamo fare. Tac, giri, tac, Si ma se ce l'hai
tutta tu. Vabbè con due mani. Tac
Tutto ciò che avete nella mani dovete metterlo nell'impasto (Rico). Raccapriccianti (Mario)
Aspetta aspetta, piano piano senza violenza
Che bello sarebbe toglierci questa roba dalle dita vero?
Questo maglione non è sponsorizzato da
nessuno. Perché non potevamo usare la forchetta? Volevi questo?...Ma perché rimane lì? (Rico)
Dovevamo usare la forchetta. Ma perché hai...perché ho ascoltato Enrico
Hai presente quando io ho fallito nella mia vita?
C'era Enrico dietro di me, vi do un suggerimento. Ma questa roba va fatta riposare? Si. Ah bene
E per quella roba pensavo parlassi della mia mano
Su, poi chiudo...chiudo, vai. Secondo me andava fatto quello per metterci la farcitura
L'impasto si tratta male (Rico). Maledetto!
Bravissimo!
I vicini penseranno altro. Questa qui ragazzi ve lo consiglio proprio come
...terapia di copia (Rico)... terapia di coppia esatto
Farina ragazzi farina...nonono...lo stiamo perdendo lo stiamo perdendo (Rico)
Non lo stiamo perdendo, lo stiamo unendo finalmente. Bravo
Auch...Era la tua pelle quella?
Eh si...Che non è così faticoso
farlo da solo...eh no...perché ci metti pure
tutto il peso corporeo, infatti dovremmo
andarci insieme di peso corporeo
Altro che palestra. Io mi ritrovo il
braccio a destra è incartapecorito
Ci siamo, chiudiamola con questo eh. Basta
continuare ad aggiungere farina, non ce la faccio più!
Secondo me è privo di farina (Rico). Tu sei privo di sensibilità, te lo posso dire?
Quella la dovete esaurire ragazzi (Rico)
C'ha ragione lui? Io lo vedo a occhio che è molle (Rico). Io a occhio vedo che sei uno s****o!
Ma tutta questa?
Nonono non ti avvicinare a queste zone...Se ciao e adesso come si fa?
Rimettilo dentro...chiudi
Ottimo! Lasciamolo riposare in un luogo fresco
per una mezz'ora. E' passata mezz'ora, la
realtà è che credo sia passata pure
...un'ora. Abbiamo fatto i cavoli nostri.
Abbiamo già aperto uno sportello, ora lo
richiudiamo e abbiamo messo anche la
pentola sul fuoco. Ma non va inquadrata la
pentola sul fuoco, è acqua in una pentola. Io stavo riprendenso quela d'olio...A questo punto
abbiamo bisogno di quella che secondo me
sarà la nostra sfida di oggi. Ok
La macchinetta per stendere la pasta, se non
ce l'avete a casa vi ho messo un link qua
sotto se volete prendervela su amazon,
altrimenti potete usare il mattarello
oppure comprarla al supermercato. Questo
va qui, questa è la manovella che quindi
dovrai girare tu e questo qui serve per
bloccarla. vai vai vai. Dai ci siamo quasi
Ok prendiamo lei...aja
Enrico c'aveva ragione,farina. Mamma mia un po' appiccicosa. Questo sai che vuol dire?
Ti rimane nel macchinario (Rico). A Enrico che
bello, che bello vederti di giorno
Ti stanno chiamando. Ma che formato volete fare (Mario)?
Vediamo che succede. Bello. Bello (Mario e Rico)...Wow
Ora...noi con l'ombelico
Dovete girare. Prendete la semola a
questo punto, di grano duro...Aspetta
Aspetta nonono non vale questo. Esatto...bravo...ok
In realtà bisognerebbe farlo proprio alla fine questo. Vai di ombelico. Vai. Wow
Eccolo qui. in realtà lo stiamo stringendo tra le
anche, capito?...Cantami una piccola canzone...posso andare...
Non devi aver paura della semola, la semola è la tua amica...Vai
...vai...vai...vai...vai
E' bellissimo (Rico). *brusio poco chiaro*
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
questo qui è il risultato che adesso
molto probabilmente mangeremo col burro
perché non abbiamo nulla col quale condire tutta questa pasta. Abbiamo fatto
un chilo con quelle che sono le quantità
e gli ingredienti che vi abbiamo detto
Io ringrazio Lu...grazie a te...per aver preso parte a
questa cosa. Ringrazio voi per seguirci
sempre. Iscrivetevi a questo canale,
attivate le notifiche per non perdere mai
nessun video e ci vediamo alla prossima
settimana. Ciao...Ciao
In realtà ci abbiamo messo sugo di spuntature, pesto, olio, formaggio. Che
cos'altro ci mancava?Non lo so...altro olio e altro olio e altro olio. E' c'è anche una specie di...polenta
L'acqua di cottura era densa...Ecco l'altra metà. Ho famissima
*Chiacchiere sovrapposte*
Comunque vi assicuro non è quella di Pasqu. Good happenning regà. Good happening
Si sente il pesto. Gu richiudi sto video. Buon appe...chiusa